Pulitzer prize-winning historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin has researched American
presidents for a half-century she got
her big break back as a 24 year old
White House Fellow for a President
Lyndon Johnson and went on to help write
his memoirs over her career she's
written extensively about the lives of
presidents Abraham Lincoln Theodore
Roosevelt and Franklin Roosevelt in her
new online masterclass course she
teaches how leadership qualities can
define a commander-in-chief and she
joins us good morning glad to be with
you thank you so I want to get into the
master class but before I do that I want
a little dose of perspective here
historians always talk about how as
troubled as are times today may seem and
by many measures they are very troubled
indeed the past was worse please tell me
how yeah there was an old woman on the
plane who said to me tell me you're in
historian where times are really worse
so I started talking about the 1850s for
worse we had this partisan press you
only believed what newspaper you were
reading the Republican the democratic or
the Whig and that she said but that
didn't end up - well it was the Civil
War so I said right right but in truth
it is true I mean what think about
Lincoln coming in and the Civil War is
about to begin the Great Depression
World War two in the early days
somehow democracy gets through these
things and we have to believe that and
one of the ways in which you say in the
master class that democracy can come
through is if we make sure that we know
each other and one of the ways to solve
that in the present day would be a
volunteer program why do you think
that's so important I feel so strongly
if I could do one thing you know like in
my 50 years of being in this kind of
life of us an historian it would be to
have a national service program just
thing Teddy Roosevelt warns that the
reason democracy will fail is if people
in the other part of the country think
of themselves as the other different
sections if you're in a national service
program you're not going to the Peace
Corps abroad necessarily you're going
from the city to the country you're
hosted by a family you're learning how
to deal with national disasters you're
helping mentoring people you get time
off from college or for college tuition
you would just know what military people
get when my son joined the army right
after 9/11 nothing will equal that he
had just graduated Harvard he'd learned
to be in a platoon with all sorts of
people it'd be great for us to
understand each other again that you
become invested in the country you know
in a different way civil in in civics
and civic
we should be teaching it in school and
we should be learning it in such ways
like this what are the characteristics
of an effective leader would you say I
think there are a bunch of them I think
there's actually a family resemblance
from my guys that I studied over these
50 years I talk about them so humility
is one yes the ability to me that's an
interesting you you acknowledge your
errors you learn from your mistakes no
empathy is so important to be able to
see other people's points of view
resilience to get through adversity the
ability to create a team where people
can argue with you where you can share
credit and you can shoulder blame and I
think most importantly is the ambition
for self becomes an ambition for
something larger in the transformative
leaders so humility acknowledging errors
when you mentioned that in the context
of past presidents you think of the
current president who famously does not
say I'm sorry does not acknowledge
errors is not known for his humility is
he is he casting a new mould of
presidential leadership or what I don't
know it seems to be the most important
thing with all those qualities is the
ability to grow if you have humility and
empathy you can learn you can learn in
office you're not going to change
fundamentally once you become president
but you're hoping that leaders grow and
it's hard to grow if you can't
acknowledge hours because then you're
never wrong so what are you going to
learn from have you gotten a chance to
speak to president Truong no I love to I
mean I've spoken to many of the other
presidents and what would you say to him
I think what I'd say to him is can I
bring Lincoln and Teddy Roosevelt and
Franklin Roosevelt and LBJ in to talk to
you tonight I'd rather they be able to
talk to him than me but I'll channel
them and you listen to them and they'll
teach you something one story you tell
is about President Lincoln Lincoln
writing what you call hot letters to his
staff what exactly so he'd get mad at
somebody right and instead of yelling
and screaming at them he would write a
letter in which he expressed all of his
anger to general Meade after he failed
failed to follow up with General Lee's
army I'm immeasurably distressed you
didn't do what I asked you to do the
war's gonna go on forever now and then
he put the letter aside hoping he would
cool down psychologically and never send
it so we never even saw these until the
20th century when suddenly you see a
whole bunch of letters to people and the
interesting thing is I was talking to
President Obama about this when I did an
exit interview I said do you have
think of doing that said what do you
mean I said well do you do that I do it
all the time I said what do you mean he
writes letters and then throws them in
the basket and they never went anywhere
it's like the draft folder of one's
tweets exactly
cold tweets rather than hot tweets all
right great story Doris Kearns Goodwin
thank you so much her new master class
is available online now